Hello, everybody. Welcome to Nutri-Sutical 101, the topic being Adaptogen R3.
What is an Adaptogen? It is a non-toxic herb that helps support your body's reaction to stress.
It helps balance your stress levels, immune system, hormone levels, and your mood swings.
The ingredients here are the non-toxic herbs, and they help rejuvenate your whole body while undergo stress.
Your adrenal system consists of thyroid, adrenals, and pituitary.
They are the first organs that are affected when you are faced with any of these life issues, especially.
Your adrenals then work in overtime when anything is out of balance, and your internal issues get expressed externally.
So that means anything that is out of balance inside of you gets expressed through symptoms that you are facing.
So make sure you give your adrenal some love, and you can find the support and more information on Adaptogen R3 by clicking this link.
Thank you!